les enjeux de ce compte à rebours avant
le premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle avec sandra cerqueira
une campagne tardive qui n'a pas duré
longtemps parasité par la guerre en
ukraine et qui aurait peu intéressé les
français
l'enjeu de ces derniers jours de
campagne et donc de mobiliser presque
trois français sur dix disent qu'ils
n'iront pas voter l'abstention pourrait
atteindre un niveau record et parmi ceux
qui iront aux urnes un tiers n'a pas
fait de choix sur donc il ya un fort
enjeu de mobilisation notamment pour
marine le pen annoncé son électorat un
profil particulièrement abstentionnistes
donc il va falloir réussir vraiment à
persuader les électeurs que c'est
important et utile d'aller voter en 2007
2012 et 2017 les candidats qui dominait
les sondages à quelques jours de
l'élection sont tous sortis en tête du
premier tour du scrutin présidentiel
puis se sont imposés au second
l'écart continue de se resserrer entre
emmanuel macron et marine le pen dans la
dernière ligne droite le
président-candidat toujours en tête avec
28 5% des intentions de vote la
candidate du r n en seconde position à
22% l'enjeu pour les autres candidats
éviter qu'une partie de l'électorat ne
se disent que les jeux sont déjà faits
si les républicains font un score en
dessous de 10% et qui récuse et noir se
situe au dessus de la recomposition à
droite effectivement être différence de
si les républicains font un meilleur
score et se situe au sud eric zemmour
dont je vraiment sur l' après 2022 qui
est important pour les républicains en
troisième position autour de 15% jean
luc mélenchon tente jusqu'au bout de
convaincre les indécis à gauche de voter
utile la 4e place devrait se jouer entre
eric zemmour et valérie pécresse
j - 6 les enjeux de cette dernière
semaine avec mes invités claire chartier
au soir est journaliste essayiste
bienvenue heureux de vous retrouver
stewart show directeur des études
politiques opinion chez vivavoice c'est
viavoice que publie et aux éditions de
l'aube avec la fondation jean jaurès
l'opinion des émotions j'accueille
également avec plaisir roland cayrol
bonsoir êtes politologue co fondateur
ancien directeur de l'institut de
sondages csa et puis alors il ya un
documentaire ce que vous avez réalisé
abstention premier parti de france qui
vient d'être diffusé sur chez nos amis
de lcp matthieu croissandeau
éditorialiste politique au jour tout ça
va mathieu ou encore la pêche avant
cette dernière ligne droite musique et
le suspense on
espère quart d'heure encore ce chiffre
pour commencer on va s'appuyer sur le
dernier baromètre de nos partenaires
notre partenaire pour les soirées
électorales instituts ipsos avec une
abstention qui est toujours évalué
autour des 70 ans né à 69% j'ai commencé
avec vous justement roland cayrol les
causes elles semblent profondes est ce
que la dernière semaine peut malgré tout
voilà infirmer ces derniers chiffres
bien sûr c'est l'enjeu principal la
dernière semaine c'est très rare dans la
dernière semaine qu'on arrive à rameuter
des électeurs hors de son camp en
revanche il faut ameuter les siens à
dire toutes les études mondiales dans
les démocraties montre que c'est la
fonction principale des élections les
campagnes électorales et notamment de la
télévision ça permet de convaincre des
gens qui a priori sont plutôt pour vous
mieux qu'il soit un peu fatigué comme
pas forcément envie d'y aller je veux
dire des 6 et bien moi votre candidat
vous devez vous identifier à moi c'est
dangereux de ne pas y aller à lézinnes
débat
d12 on va dire avant le premier tour
toutes les télés toutes les grandes
radios on invite tous les candidats dans
leur prime time donc voilà il ya là un
potentiel de huy un tout petit peu plus
indigeste que les fois précédentes avec
parce que les antennes notamment des
chaînes d'information continue sont
occupées par le cren et que du coup ils
font un peu d'aidé des couloirs un peu
longuet consacrer uniquement à la
présidentielle dont si j'ai bien compris
les audiences sont pas faramineuses donc
si les gens se garde pas ça aide pas
être convaincu il ya là une petite
difficulté de cette campagne qui est que
les médias et ils ont joué d'abord le
sujet principal à leurs yeux et aux yeux
de l'opinion puisque c'est ça qui fait
de l'audience ils ont joué l'ukraine et
du coup il ya moins de passion pour ce
qu'il se passe sur le terrain politique
mais pierre chartier si on l'a on va se
projeter beaucoup dans cette dernière
semaine mais si on jette un coup d'oeil
dans le rétro du week-end je vous
demande pas d'aller très très loin mais
est-ce que les les meetings week-end ont
fait un peu bouger les lignes d'après
vous finalement chacun est resté dans
son couloir je pense que bon il ya
effectivement des améliorations
notamment dans quand pécresse parce
qu'elle était quand même meilleur et
plus à l'aise dans son meeting que les
épisodes précédents donc effectivement
il son propre camp s'est réjoui cela
mais je pense pas que ça change
fondamentalement sur le fond on est là
face à un grand vertige qui se profile
quand même c'est que tous les candidats
sont face à un risque majeur déjà des
partis de gouvernement la gauche allait
au bord de l'extinction la droite elle
est quand même au plus mal et
effectivement on sent aussi chez valérie
pécresse une forme de projections déjà
dans les législatives donc et donc ces
deux partis de gouvernement sont dans
une situation tout à fait inédite pour
mélenchon et pour le pen c'est vraiment
là le dernier la dernière marche si ça
passe très bien si ça ne passe pas assez
il ne se représenteront pas emmanuel
macron on verra tout à l'heure l'écart
se resserre dans les sondages donc lui
qui partait vraiment très très très
favoris là on sent que le suspense est
en train de monter donc je pense que
c'est vraiment un moment très
particulier et cette épreuve là et qui
ne sera certainement pas modifiée par je
ne sais même pas si à la marge dans les
interviews que mentionnée sur sur le
halal à la suite de la neige dès 20
heures d
ou
les les interviews radio démasqué ce
qu'il tente façon c'est qu'aussi
normalement dans une campagne
présidentielle l'intérêt va croissant au
fur et à mesure que l'échéance se
rapproche et là c'est plutôt l'inversé
qui se produit alors certes
effectivement le cren occupe tous les
esprits mais c'est l'amour ça montre
bien quand même qu'il a il ya là quelque
chose qui se passe alors il ya quand
même je le disais en titre un
resserrement des des cours dont on va
regarder les tendances et l'âge mais je
m'appuie de nouveau sur le dernier
baromètre ipsos on a regardé on a pris
quinze jours dynamique depuis le 21 mars
emmanuel macron est aujourd'hui à 26
ennemis y perd quatre points deux
semaines marine le pen était à 21 elle
en gagne 4 jean luc mélenchon et états
et est à 16 pardon il faut que ce soit
précis parce que si je chine bric dans
le champ et 1,16 il gagne trois points
eric zemmour à 10 ennemis est stable il
était à 10% valérie pécresse elle perd
des deux des points elle est à huit
ennemis - ennemi et yannick jadot à 5
ennemis moins un point en deux semaines
si ward chaud cette remontée de marine
le pen dans les sondages est ce qu'elle
peut quand même remobiliser une partie
de l'électorat des manuels macron en
tout cas c'est la carte on a bien vu que
lui joué que d'autres jouent dans pas
parmi ces neuf en france où c'est tout
l'enjeu pour emmanuel macron dans ce
premier et possiblement aussi dans ce
second tour puisque je pense que le
match retour qui s'il se confirme entre
marine le pen et emmanuel macron ne se
passera pas forcément dans la même
manière qu'il ya cinq ans pour plusieurs
raisons effectivement marine le pen
apparaît dans cette campagne dans cette
fin de campagne comme la candidate de
cette forme de radicalité apaisées elles
profitent d'eric zemmour qui est un
formidable de paratonnerre qui lui
permet à la fois de recentrer sa posture
et de recentrer aussi son image et ça on
le voit dans toutes les enquêtes
d'opinion d'ailleurs on a réalisé une
enquête nous chez viavoice qui montrent
que c'est la candidate sur les deux
dernières semaines à avoir l'image qui
s'est le plus améliorée auprès des
français très loin devant emmanuel
macron jean luc mélenchon est sur le
podium donc on voit bien effectivement
qu'il ya une dynamique marine le pen qui
est évidente pour le prêt de la
république je pense qu'il ya deux
difficultés la première c'est que cette
immunité présidentielle qui lui a été
conférée en temps de crise notamment
évidemment pendant la guerre en ukraine
qui continue à sévir elle semble pour
l'instant s'étioler un petit peu ça je
pense que deux premières le premier
point le deuxième point c'est que
finalement on se rend compte qu'il ya un
électorat de conquête en 2007 d'emmanuel
macro qui est plus toujours
systématiquement prêts à voter emmanuel
macron dès le premier tour voire même au
second tour et je pense que c'est
l'enjeu aussi des manuels vacances et
d'aller chercher on pas son socle
électoral qui est encore très solide un
plus de 80% des électeurs d'emmanuel
maquereau en 2017 seraient prêts à
revoter pour lui en 2022 oui mais c'est
celle ci reste autour de 26 27 il faut
aussi une au dessus
mais c'est vraiment d'aller chercher
cette allure à deux conquêtes qui semble
pour le coup moins systématique en
termes de report de voix mathieu un
premier intervention rapide sur le
week-end politique je sais pas s'il ya
une image une
déclaration
qui ressort c'est plutôt une bonne image
parce que le ses meetings en asie marque
peu parce qu'ils ont peu été vus parce
qu'ils ont un peu été diffusés par les
chaînes info
les districts de temps de parole et donc
ils on pouvait les voir sur les sites
internet ou sur les applis mais faut
vraiment être ultra motivés pour aller
regarder un meeting sur l'assurance mart
phone ou sur sur son ordinateur à samedi
après midi à dimanche a réuni 1 c'est sa
touche vraiment que des gens qui étaient
plutôt l'avis des militants et moi je
trouve que du coup le meeting du modem
macron est un condensé de sa mauvaise
campagne parce que les manuels mac ont
fait une mauvaise campagne il pensait
tout ou sulfater ans dans une campagne
express voilà en fait ils dégringolent
il est selon sa déclaration de
candidature à l'ue avait fait gagner des
points et depuis n'a cessé de
dégringoler avec il est pris à contre
temps je trouve sur à peu près tout il
avait en gros une présomption de
crédibilité très supérieure à tous les
autres candidats parce qu'il est en
poste et elle est sérieusement entamée
par cette affaire mckinsey qui n'a pas
vu venir et qu'il n'a pas su dominer ce
président qui demandent conseil et qui
paye très cher ses conseils je
caricature à dessein bien sûr et c'est
ça qui en fait en termes sa crédibilité
ça principales mesures sont proches de
gilad présenté vers 4h10 vous souvenez
de sa conférence de presse le meeting
durée 2h10 qu'ont retenu les gens c'est
une disposition punitive c'est la
promesse à 60,55 est vécue comme telle
par les français oui c'est positif pour
les gens qui veulent équilibrer les
comptes publics mais les gens de ne pas
comme ça ils regardent pour eux ils on
va devoir travailler plus longtemps donc
c'est essentiellement une mesure
punitive et puis ensuite sa campagne
avec très peu de déplacements de terrain
un meeting en période égalité stricte de
temps de parole alors que s'il avait
fait une semaine plus tôt
diffusée partout là pour le coup ça n'a
pas ça n'a pas grand sens pour des
grands stratèges se disant à l'elysée et
dans son qg de campagne je trouve que
c'est pas très réussi alors on va faire
un zoom sur le la campagne meeting de
valérie pécresse et je propose à steam
jourdain de nous rejoindre bonsoir steve
avec un on peut dire un nicolas sarkozy
qui d'une certaine façon cette invitée à
ce meeting trouvait alors il était à
l'origine officiellement est très très
cordialement invités mais il a décliné
cette invitation du coup l'ancien
président n'était pas là physiquement
mais il s'est quand même en quelque
sorte invité à ce meeting de valérie
pécresse son nom a été prononcé à la
tribune il a été hué sifflé à deux
reprises par les militants les militants
qui lui reprochent son silence et son
absence de soutien à valérie pécresse
flora sauvage et quentin qu'elle mais
était sur place écouter les dernières
nouvelles sur sarkozy et peut-être même
parti ou à appeler à voter macron alors
je sais pas je sais pas où est la vérité
aujourd'hui je sais c'est que monsieur
macron a été élu avec des républicains
et pour moi c'est impossible qu'ils
puissent prendre une telle décision donc
si peu clarifié la situation plus au
plus vite ce serait très très très
intéressant parce que dans huit jours ou
qu'un jour il sera trop tard elle a de
son côté valérie pécresse est revenu sur
les sifflets dirigée contre nicolas
sarkozy pendant le meeting elle parle
des lecteurs triste ce matin sur rtl
écoutez la tous les orateurs qui ont
pris la parole dans le meeting d'hier on
parlait de nicolas sarkozy avec beaucoup
de respect ils ont fait applaudir s'il y
a eu au début du meeting quelques
électeurs triste c'est la réalité voilà
c'est la réalité il vous met à nu un
triste
nous avons nous avons avec infiniment de
respect fait applaudir nicolas qui l'a
fait plus partout le rôle qu'il a eu
c'est pour la france là cette
information de nos confrères de rtl
valérie pécresse a tenté de joindre
nicolas sarkozy dans la meeting dans la
foulée du meeting pas de réponse de la
part de nicolas sarkozy nicolas sarkozy
dont on est qu'ils voudraient prendre
part à la recomposition qui s'annonce à
droite à partir de ce dimanche on parle
même d' échanges entre emmanuel macron
est dit nicolas sarkozy autour d'une
grande coalition à l'allemande et la
répartition pourquoi pas de
circonscription en prévision des
élections législatives pour l'instant
beaucoup de rumeurs rien ne fait rien de
confirmé ce qui est sûr thomas c'est ça
le soutien de françois fillon à valérie
pécresse anciens prime premier ministre
de nicolas sarkozy a officiellement
apporté son soutien ce lundi à la
candidate la démocratie c'est d'abord la
possibilité de l'alternance valérie
pécresse constitue aujourd'hui le seul
chemin de l'alternance voilà ces défis
françois fillon aujourd'hui merci steve
pour ce rappel de voilà ces deux
séquences un peu particulière quand même
roland cayrol valérie pécresse qui tombe
on l'a vu un donne dans le baromètre à
huit ennemis mois 1,5 point en deux
semaines quand j'ai lu ça et puis quand
on voit la tendance un peu comme si les
électeurs avaient fait déjà leur deuil
de ce parti de l'air est ce que vous
aller jusque là puis je crois que c'est
tout à fait c'est tout à fait le cas il
ya plus de l'utilité aux républicains
pas plus qu'au parti socialiste que le
maquereau est en train de finir le
travail politique il avait commencé en
2017 en éliminant pratiquement de la vie
politique mais pas tout à fait cette
fois ci ça va être le cas les deux
parties qui nous ont gouvernés pendant
une quarantaine d'années leur mission
historique et comme terminée ils ont
appliqué leur programme ils sont
totalement essoufflé incapable d'abord
de réaliser ce qui leur est arrivé et de
réagir de rebondir avec des idées
nouvelles ou des personnes nouvelles
cette histoire sur sarkozy par exemple
tous les anciens présidents tombent dans
cette maladie ce syndrome de croire que
les autres qui veulent leur succéder
sont des nains et que peu seul eux seuls
peuvent arriver à avoir un contact fort
avec les français la vérité est tout
autre quand on s'est débarrassé d'un
président ne veut plus le revoir c'est
un intérêt médiatique savoir que fait le
président de cody le président en a qui
parlent le président mais les français
s'en moquent totalement
il aurait pris position ça n'aurait rien
changé aux élections il faut maintenant
que les dirigeants politiques à
commencer par madame pécresse
s'intéresse un peu à la politique dont
qui est vraiment celle qui intéresse les
français pierre chartier est ce que est
ce qu'on doit donner une interprétation
politique à ces sifflets contre nicolas
sarkozy
après tout c'est quoi c'est peut-être
quelques dizaines de personnes dans un
meeting comment comment
c'est fait quand même plusieurs
plusieurs jours plusieurs semaines qu'on
parle effectivement du silence de
nicolas sarkozy de son éventuel
ralliement à mâcon mais je pense surtout
que c'est une erreur tactique de valérie
pécresse énorme parce que quand on quand
on se présente à la présidentielle bon
on est censé incarner une forme
d'autorité
voilà verticalité et là on a en fait une
candidate qui court après un ancien
président et qui quémandent son soutien
et qui en plus ne l'a ne l'obtient pas
et qu ils appellent enfin c'est je
trouve que l'image est absolument
désastreuse et ne sert pas du tout en
plus effectivement sa démarche
présidentielle donc de ce point de vue
là c'est mais pour revenir sur justement
cette droite gauche qui est en train de
sombrer je trouve que on a put souvent
emmanuel macron précisément tout ce
travail de deux finalement de
dissolution du clivage mais il n'a pas
été le seul en fait le pop et les
populistes en tant que tel c'est tout à
fait leur travail aussi en fait ce qui
s'emploie à faire et très bien puisque
eux ils veulent redessiner à notre axe
qui leur permet de croiser la droite et
la gauche d'ailleurs c'est surtout par
le peuple et surtout marine le pen tout
à fait c'est le peuple contre l'élite
donc en fait les les candidats
populistes ont eux aussi beaucoup aux
vrais à ça donc je trouve que l'analyse
par rapport à emmanuel macron sur ce
point là elle et on peut pas totalement
lui faire grief de ça on peut lui faire
grief d'autres choses à me sens à mon
âge jusqu'à la fouille mais on peut lui
faire quand même un bon sens là un vrai
griefs et on en parlera peut-être mais
c'est de n'avoir pas su lier on parlait
tout à l'heure de sa campagne ne fait
qu'en fait il n'a pas fait campagne
c'est surtout qu' il ne s'est pas lié à
les éléments de sa de son libéralisme
philosophique et politique en fait on a
des mesures il nous les présente mais en
fait tout cela ne fait pas sans une
certaine manque de vision quand ça ne
fait pas un projet qui pourrait lever le
soupçon d'un président qui est tout à
son aventure personnelle et et qui au
final m'en serais totalement imprégné de
la vision néolibérale en fait du coup il
apparaît comme ceux braconniers
effectivement politique qui va tendre
ces pièges à droite et à gauche dans une
forme d'opportunisme et dans une forme
d' aventure personnelle alors qu'en fait
il a certainement des convictions mais
je n'arrive toujours pas à saisir
pourquoi il ne lit pas entre eux ces
éléments pour en faire quelque chose de
cohérent je pense que hausse est parce
qu elles ont quand même été balayé par
la crise sanitaire
mu est
assez intéressante quand même lors de sa
conférence de presse qui a quand même
duré un certain temps d'ailleurs il
était un petit peu partis là-dessus un
moment lorsqu'il parle d'un projet et on
sentait s'opposer à la proposition de
zemmour dans une vision dans un regard
de la société puis en fait il a très peu
développé sa cette idée de projet
républicain il est revenu sur des
goûters sur des aspects très techniques
donc outre le fait qu'il n'a pas voulu
se prêter au jeu du débat qui à mon sens
pour moi était une erreur parce que ça
voulait dire moi je dessine même si les
citoyens ou envie moi j'ai pas envie
donc je ne joue pas donc ça je trouve qu
en démocratie c'est un problème mais
donc il n'a pas pu provoquer finalement
cette rencontre avec les citoyens mais
en plus à mon sens il a fait cette
erreur moi je projetais sur sur le
second tour et la stratégie des uns et
les autres dans un instant et vous
mathieu mais c'est cette histoire de
débat on en a déjà parlé sur ce plateau
mais c'est intéressant c'est un vrai ça
reste est ce que ça imprime dans
l'opinion c'est la preview stewart je
trouve que refus des macros oui je
trouve que depuis le début de la
campagne on s'interroge sur le
désintérêt des français pour cette
campagne en inversant parfois les rolls
et qu'il faudrait que l'opinion publique
est un intérêt pour que derrière on
propose des choses qui intéressent les
électeurs mais je pense que celle
inverse ce qu'il faut faire c'est
qu'effectivement il ya un intérêt
naturel des français dans ce temps comme
inquiets l'introspection un peu national
que constitue l'élection présidentielle
emmanuel macron la difficulté qu'il a
aujourd'hui c'est de créer un programme
désirable c'est-à-dire qu'elle
désirabilité on propose quand on fait 5
ans un peu empêché et qu'on va proposer
effectivement un ensemble de mesures qui
peuvent être cohérent dans le fond mais
qui n'apportent pas une réelle vision
c'est une campagne qui est complètement
des idéologisé aujourd'hui et on aurait
pu penser finalement que le l'émergence
d'un eric zemmour aurait pu constituer
la confrontation d'idées aux journées
soit une campagne qui aujourd'hui
propulse un défi l'incarnation et ce
défi d'incarnation en a qui ressorte
plus ou moins plus ou moins vainqueur et
je termine juste sur sur valérie
pécresse parce qu'on en parlait tout à
l'heure sur l'utilité aujourd'hui de la
droite effectivement la question qui se
pose c'est quelle est la raison d'être
d'une droite aujourd'hui qui est à la
fois tiraillé entre une extrême droite
bicéphale avec l'une d'entre elles qui
sert recentrer une droite
je dirais un centre droit un peu
libérale représenté par emmanuel macron
c'est compliqué d'un point de vue
politique c'est quand même assez
problématique à mon sens je repose la
question sur le débat oui répond nous
vient pas des gens qui vont voter contre
emmanuel macron parce qu'il a refusé de
participer à un débat aux premiers noms
et marques je veux dire non mais mais
qui vont pas voter contre mais peut-être
qu'il va voter pour elle et je pense que
la question elle est là aussi c'est à
dire c'est qu'il est le père du des voix
je pense je ne sais pas s'il a perdu les
vois je pense qu'il a perdu
effectivement un électorat peut-être de
conquête qu'il faut aller conquérir
qu'il faut aller convaincre une des
élections présidentielles c'est cela les
français attendu de cette élection
présidentielle c'est faux de dire que
les français étaient complètement au
final des intéressés par ce temps
politique au contraire je pense qu'il
aurait fallu qu'ils aient une vraie
campagne je termine juste à léser les
deux chiffres qui vont être publiés dans
la semaine par nos confrères de
libération et la majorité des français
qui considèrent aujourd'hui qu'il n'y a
pas eu de campagne la majorité des
français considère qu'il n'y a pas eu de
campagne et vous avez près de 7 français
sur 10 qui considèrent ressentir de
l'amertume déjà par rapport à cette
campagne vous voyez je pense que ça veut
dire aussi quelque chose de l'état
politique du pays mais ça nous amène à
nous projeter évidemment c'est ce qu'on
va faire avec vous mathieu parce que bon
gars maintien suspense est encore
beaucoup d'abstentionnistes est encore
beaucoup d'indécis mais malgré tout il
se réduit à chaque jour qui passe et
vous avez le sentiment que les candidats
eux se projette déjà ils sont nombreux
dans l'entre-deux tours oui parce que
sauf surprise sauf plantage généralisée
de tous les sondages ce qui n'est pas
arrivé depuis 20 ans et même y avait un
ton si toujours le parallèle avec 2000
2001 2002
média j'arrêtais qui était assez serré
mais tout semble indiquer qu'ils
menaient le maquereau et marine le pen
s'affronteront au second tour on peut
s'en désoler on peut vouloir faire
mentir les intentions de vote mais des
principaux concernés eux sont déjà dans
le coup d'après prenez manuel macron à
mesure que ses intentions de vote
refonde on en parlait tout à l'heure et
que l'écart se resserre il ajoute de
plus en plus le chiffon noir de
l'extrême droite puis il est déjà dans
l'entre-deux tours il a dit à fouras la
semaine dernière j'ai moins entendu dire
qu'elle est d'extrême droite à propos de
marine le pen il ya vingt ans les médias
que vous étiez disait c'est terrible
front républicain les forces politiques
républicaines disait jamais il n'y a
plus cette réaction là il est semblait
s'en désole son défi à lui en fait c'est
ça c'est de ressusciter de tenter de
ressusciter le fameux front républicain
qu'est ce qu'un sacré chantier parce que
c'est que les électeurs de gauche font
beaucoup traîné les pieds cette fois ci
jean luc mélenchon qui avait déjà
cultivé une forme d'ambiguïté en 2017 a
déjà prévenu qu'il consulterait ses
troupes et puis lui s'en tire par une
pirouette 1 il dit qu'il va pas être le
roi des castors les castors ça fait des
barrages et il dit si vous avez
l'intention de faire un barrage au
second tour j'ai une proposition plus
intéressante à vous faire fait le
barrage dès le premier tour en votant
pour nous al'inverse yannick jadot pour
les écolos lui explique que les
écologistes n'ont jamais hésité à
construire des front républicain contre
l'extrême droite fabien roussel lui pour
lui c'est clair il ne laissera jamais
l'extrême droite mettre la main sur le
public et il appellera à faire barrage
ils se sont montrés extrêmement claire
anne hidalgo s'était montré extrêmement
clair
avant la l'été dernier je n'ai pas
entendu ni revu parler du du front
républicain le seul problème c'est que
tous ces leaders peuvent bien parler
mais ce qui seront suivis ça c'est la
vraie interrogation vraiment pas sûr que
les électeurs de gauche se sentent
concernés par cette élection au second
tour s'il n'est pas un peu dramatiser
n'y a pas d'enjeu alors si on fait
maintenant un gros plan sur marine le
pen mais son défi elle c'est de
constituer le front anti macron donc
c'est une logique un peu différente elle
n'y était pas parvenu en 2017 mais on
l'a dit dit fois l alice est à la fois
son programme d son image a bénéficié de
du contre et fait et vous enfin de
l'effet plutôt à contrario de de zemmour
et puis le temps maintenant à la main
aux électeurs de droite et de gauche
donc pour amorcer ce front anti macron
du second tour écouter ce qu'elle
déclarait c'était la semaine dernière
vendredi à stiring wendel en moselle je
sais aussi qu'il existe une gauche
patriote
consciente du caractère protecteur de la
nation convaincu de l'importance d'une
laïcité apaisée parce que respecter une
gauche attachée aux messages
d'émancipation des peuples et des hommes
que porte la france c'est un tout ce que
je m'adresse
marine le pen qui tend la main toute la
gauche c'est quand même assez paradoxal
enfin c est une première mais pour la
première fois de sa vie elle est dans
une situation un peu plus confortable
que la dernière fois d'abord parce
qu'elle dispose de réserves de voix on
en a parlé de celle d'eric zemmour elle
devrait faire le plein là et on sait que
chez modèle de chez parlons jean luc
mélenchon bas une partie des électeurs
mélenchonistes se dirigèrent elle alors
savary sont les enquêtes pour ipsos
c'était on va dire un cinquième des
électeurs pourrait lab la semaine
dernière c'était clairement un tiers des
électeurs qui comprend la totalité des
électeurs jean luc mélenchon potentiel
au premier tour et un tiers voteraient
pour marine le pen au second tour et
seulement après pour emmanuel macron
c'est quand même c'est même beaucoup au
pied alors il ya des candidats qui se
projette carrément au delà de la
présidence à un regard là on n'est plus
qu'à un mandant retourné après alors ça
c'est anne hidalgo par exemple qui a
appelé dimanche à reconstruire la gauche
offrait qui se projette évidemment la
suite il faut comprendre reconstruire la
gauche avec elle là aussi on écoute
c'était au cirque d'hiver à paris c'est
pour ça que je vous le dis
rejoignez notre famille votre famille
d'origine celle de la gauche dure elle
et de la raison celle qui reconnaît ses
erreurs donnez lui la chance de porter
les valeurs humanistes auxquelles vous
adhérez donnez lui la chance
[Applaudissements]
se réinventer se reconstruire
sous-entendu avec elle déjà inquiets sur
le créneau un françois hollande qui a
fait déjà des idées et des propositions
plus ou moins dissimulées notamment lors
d'un meeting d'anne hidalgo donc elle
sait qu'elle sera pas seul on prend un
autre exemple valérie pécresse on en
parlait tout à l'heure elle est là une
petite phrase qui était intéressante ce
dimanche notre lors de son meeting à la
porte de versailles l'a dit vous m'avez
vu trébucher me relever vous avez
découvert ma résistance je ne lâche rien
sous-entendu il faudra compter sur moi
pour la suite si on compte reconstruire
ce qu'il reste de la droite c'est un
avertissement lancé à xavier bertrand
dans vos quai ou avec ciotti il faudra
compter avec elle aussi alors il ya
beaucoup de thématiques on a déjà un peu
évoquée mais j'aurais quand même vous
vous entendre lassus peut-être claire
chartier sur le cette espèce jeu reprend
les propos de des manades macron quand
il dit il ya vingt ans les médias vous
utilisez ces terribles front républicain
les forces politiques républicaines
disait jamais ya plus cette réaction là
ici une sorte d' acclimatation
collective
c'est vrai que c'est quand même tout à
fait d'eux non parce que ces deux
campagnes ça allait quand même
historique de ce point de vue là c'est à
dire qu'on a quand même 30 % des
français qu'ils disent qu'ils ont
l'intention de voter pour l'extrême
droite donc qui sont séduits par les
idées d'extrême droite alors que en fait
c'est comme une une lente montée du
désir qu'on regarde qu on ausculte
vraiment avec force aux commentaires et
d'une façon très très pointu mais
finalement sans qu'il y ait en face de
la part des partis de gouvernement de
réponse satisfaisante et donc on se
retrouve avec un dénouement probable en
effet emmanuel macron marine le pen avec
une marine le pen en meilleure position
jean même que qu'il ya cinq ans sans
avoir su entraver la marche du destin en
fait donc il ya quand même quelque chose
là de l'ordre de la tragédie enfin je
trouve que cette campagne elle est
passionnant de ce point de vue là est
particulièrement préoccupante quant au
front républicain physiquement c'est
plus en france est un c'est un éboulis
enfin c'est mais il faut se rappeler que
le front républicain c'est une
expression qui est né sous la plume de
jean jacques servan shreiber en 1956 aux
législatives pour désigner le front qui
s'est constitué la coalition de centre
gauche qui devait faire pièce aux
mouvements de pierre poujade pierre
poujade à l'époque étaient des était en
deçà de l'extrême droite de l'époque il
était beaucoup moins une dalle est
beaucoup moins loin dans l'anti
parlementarisme et dans l'anti
républicanisme aujourd'hui on a quand
même marine le pen quand on regarde bien
son son programme qui va quand même qui
bat en brèche des valeurs
constitutionnelles des valeurs
humanistes qui étaient censés être les
nôtres donc c'est vrai que lorsqu'on
regarde ça dans le détail on ne peut
qu'être stupéfait par effectivement les
cartes qui semble être aujourd'hui sur
la table face à cette perspective donc
je pense pas qu'il ait finalement il n'a
pas grand-chose à faire emmanuel macron
pour agiter ce spectre là parce qu'il
est là je veux dire l'extrême droite à
30% c'est jean luc mélenchon nous un
chapitre consacré aux candidats
de la france insoumise le fondateur +3
points en deux semaines dans le
baromètre ipsos il était hier à tous
vous écoutez je craignais on entend dans
cette campagne quand je la vis si mal
engagée par des luttes dérisoire et des
compétitions secondaire lorsque pendant
tout le mois de décembre tout le mois de
novembre
nous fûmes arras et
d'intervention sur le thème tout est
perdu puisque la carte ne s'est pas
marié avec le lapin puisque la chèvre ne
veux pas faire ça août avec le chou tout
est perdu eh bien nous n'avons jamais
cédé et d'heure en heure jour après jour
nous n'avons pas compter sur la dispute
nous n'avons pas compter sur l'adulte
nous avons compté sur la conviction le
travail patient d'explication de
programme
voilà jean luc mélenchon qui trie
pourquoi ça ne servait à rien de faire
l'union de la gauche avant avant le
début de cette campagne présidentielle
six morceaux vous publié demain dans
dans libération une enquête justement
autour du vote mélenchon le vote utile
vote efficace pour reprendre sa
formulation ça fonctionne pour lui il ya
plusieurs points le premier c'est
effectivement il est dans une dynamique
est réel selon les derniers chiffres de
mes confrères de chez harris il est à 17
% et + 2 en quelques jours donc c'est
assez assez fort ça peut être la
surprise de ce premier tour s'il atteint
et le de second tour vont tout ça est
hypothétique mais dans une réelle
dynamique effectivement il ya plusieurs
points soulevés le premier c'est que
faut le dire c'est le leader aujourd'hui
incontesté à gauche là l'étude que l'on
sortira qu on publiera ce dans
libération montre que c'est à la fois le
vote le plus crédible vote plus utile et
le vote pour les électeurs de gauche
pour le candidat qui fait le plus
président aujourd'hui donc très loin
devant jadot très loin devant hidalgo ou
qui fait des scores assez assez probant
pour autant ces scores ils sont en
dessous de 50% donc ça montre aussi qu
auprès des électeurs de gauche tous ne
sont pas encore convaincus et je pense
qu'il ya deux coups deux obstacles je
dirai à la surprise mélenchon le premier
obstacle c'est effectivement faire
ramener à lui des électeurs de gauche
qui sont aujourd'hui pas encore prêts à
voter mélenchon même dans un duel macro
mélenchon
donc ça je pense que c'est très
important de soigner deuxième point
c'est de mélenchon il n'est jamais aussi
fort qu'en le taux d'abstention est
assez bas c'est à dire que il a été très
fort sur les catégories de la population
qui traditionnellement votre - il fait
30 % chez les 18-24 primo votants en
2017 est ce que cette année ils vont
revoter pour lui il est aux alentours de
23 % par les intentions de vote donc ça
c'est le premier élément
deuxième élément il fait quand même un
score non négligeable chez les ouvriers
en 2010 est fait à peu près 24 % c'est
le second score après marine le pen donc
est ce que là aussi il va pouvoir
capitaliser dessus et le troisième
élément c'est sur les demandeurs
d'emploi il fait plus de 30 % en 2017 et
en fait quand on met tout ça en
perspective on se rend compte que cette
sociologie électorale il la partage avec
marine le pen donc en fait les deux
dynamiques suivre donc finalement oui il
ya une surprise mélenchon il ya une
dynamique mélenchon mais aussi dynamique
marine le pen qui lui semble aussi lui
faire un petit peu écran et qui
potentiellement peut lui faire barrage
évidemment pour atteindre ce qu'on le
second tour ce qu'on a bien compris
roland cayrol rebondit sur ce que disait
jean luc mélenchon dans l'extrait qu'on
a choisi oui le mot pour enfants ce
qu'ils disaient il faut absolument faire
l'union de la gauche c'est comme si les
sondages avait joué une rôle des
primaires voyez ce que je veux dire au
fur et à mesure que la campagne avance
et ben voilà il ya un lien il ya un
leader qui s'est dégagée au sein de la
gauche qui aspire petite attaque selon
lui l'analyse qui fait que c'est plus
profond chez lui ça fait plus de six ans
qu'il n'a pas employé une seule fois le
mot gauche il n'a aucun rapport
conceptuel avec ce qu'il appelle la
gauche ils sont ces gens qui prouve pour
lui sont dans la magouille la discussion
permanente la possibilité à avoir des
solutions qui soient adaptées aux
peuples tel qu'il est lui il voulait
faire l'unité populaire l'union
populaire ce la fédération république
est ça a pris beaucoup de noms mais ça
n'a jamais été la grosse caisse qui est
intéressant c'est d'arriver à faire que
quand même
comme il a été de gauche c'est un clamé
de la gauche il a quand même longtemps
été sénateur socialiste groupe ben ça
allez ça a créé des liens tels que des
électeurs de gauche s'il a quand même
insulté pendant toute la campagne qui
sont quand même tenter maintenant de
voter pour lui en se disant quand même
c'est la famille quoi et ça c'est un
assez gros exploit arrivé à cogner sur
tous les alliés potentiels dire qu'on
n'a rien à faire avec eux est arrivé
quand même à séduire un peu la base la
fameuse union à la base qui rappelle
aussi des choses dans l'histoire
politique de la gauche il faut lui
reconnais ça il sait le faire
malheureusement pour lui ça n'arrivera
pas ce corps telles que ça lui assure
une présence au second tour et vous en
êtes certain temps oui il ramena
surprise de ce côté là où ira le gpu le
faire
en 2017 il allait regarder du côté
l'électorat ligne open avec ces fachos
pas fâché et là en fait on à linverse
qui se produit parce qu'effectivement la
dynamique et certains faisait lecture
continuer comme ça en effet mais il
l'avait vraiment formalisé dans ses
discours et c'était une tactique là il
l'entend pas du tout cette tactique là
c'est plutôt l inverse puisqu'il se
reportent sur la gauche puisqu'il ya que
des orphelins à gauche et donc il se dit
que là il a bien davantage de chances
d'aller glaner des voix que de l'autre
côté puisque la marine le pen est en
meilleure posture alors l'une des
phrases un peu frappante quand même 2 2
ce week-end elle a été prononcée par
emmanuel macron ans son unique meeting
de candidate avant le premier tour
c'était samedi coup de barre à gauche il
reprend même un slogan du nouveau parti
anticapitaliste nos vies valent plus que
leurs profits ce qui n'a pas manqué de
faire réagir philippe poutou
11e' quel culot quel culot apprécieront
se dit que si on avait su on aurait
breveté le truc comme ça ne rigole plus
d'argent puisque en fait aux digues
certaine manière on est devenu un
cabinet conseil mais macron et sa bande
ils ont géré les choses comme ça et puis
maintenant ils peuvent faire un peu à
mais c'est vrai quand même la course aux
profits c'est dégueulasse et puis en
reprenant dans des solos du npa où elle
sert bon voilà c'est cynique et ça
montre que
on espère que derrière ça ça met en
évidence l'urgence qu'il ya de
reconstruire des services publics six
morceaux ça peut marcher ça auprès des
électeurs de gauche qui avaient voté
macron ya cinq ans et qui n'hésite à le
faire cette fois-ci c'est symptomatique
de ce qu'on s'est dit c'est à dire que à
la fois on se dit finalement son cirque
électoral reste solide c'est à dire s'il
y avait eu des dégoûtés du maquereau
nisme qui avaient voté pour lui en 2017
au premier tour et qui ne voterai plus
pour lui au deuxième tour on serait pas
du tout sur une reconduction à plus de
80% donc on se dit tiens il ya quand
même un électorat de conquête qu'il a
réussi à conquérir et qui reste
aujourd'hui mobilisaient pour emmanuel
macron est ce que je trouve intéressant
c'est que finalement il joue peut-être
aussi là le second tour parce qu'il sait
très bien qu'aujourd'hui la conquête va
se faire beaucoup plus sur son aile
gauche aujourd'hui que son aile droite
qu'il a plutôt convaincu je vous donne
quelques chiffres sur mais aimer mes
confrères vous avez à peu près seulement
moins d'un électeur sur deux sur deux
hidalgo moins d'un électeur sur deux
jadot et un tiers seulement des
électeurs j'en ai mis l'enfant qui
serait prêt à se reporter sur un mode
macro au second tour face à marine le
pen c'est peu c'est très très peu et ce
report de voix si c'était systématique
systémique je dirais depuis depuis 2010
est il n'est pas aujourd'hui assuré
point emmanuel macron il le sait et
c'est je pense à ça aujourd'hui il
travaille mais ce qui nous projette
évidemment dans les le baromètre ipsos
pour le second tour alors regardez ce
que nous proposent nos partenaires pour
pour les deux soirées électorales sur
public sénat et lcp
emmanuel macron battrait on me dit
évidemment des conditionnels marine le
pen de jolis points 54 46 mais ce qu'on
a fait pour les scores du premier tour
on l'a fait aussi pour les évaluations
du second
il ya deux semaines l'écart était de 22
points c'était 61 39 et puis dans
l'hypothèse jean luc mélenchon qui a été
également testé par ipsos
le président sortant l'emporterait 58,40
deux là aussi l'écart se réduit
fortement le 21 mars il était de 64 36
il ya pas de mal quand même c'est comme
quand on rentre dans la campagne du
second tour c'est pas tout à fait les
mêmes systèmes et les mêmes
préoccupations pour l'essentiel c'est
qu'à un moment on se dit on n'exprime
plus forcément ses positions ne l'est
plus forcément sa colère on se dit et
qui on donne les clés du camion et si je
peux me permettre et pour le coup c'est
là où on commence on recommence tout
c'est dit avec qui gouverne marine le
pen avec qui gouverner le maquereau est
là va quand même y avoir un effet
d'image et de comparaison donc vous
pensez que ces écarts cet écart là
le débat va reprendre sur la crédibilité
d'une certaine façon qui est capable et
avec qui ça peut ça peut faire pour l'un
souviens je me souviens d'un temps que
les moins de 20 ans peuvent connaître
qui est celui où tous les grands médias
et tous les instituts de sondage avait
promis que ça n'avait pas de sens de
faire des sondages de la tension
deuxième tour avant le premier tour et
qu'il ne veut n'en ferait plus jamais on
se souvenait de cette promesse dommage
qu'il n'ait pas tenu parce qu ils tous
ces chiffres sur les reports de voix
seront balayés d'accord parce que
l'habitude parce que pourquoi parce que
ça va dépendre des scores du premier
juste terminé ma mission on ne peut pas
se projeter quand on répond à un sondage
le premier tour sur les enjeux du second
non non non seulement on veut pas se
projeter bien on se projette très
différemment la façon dont on le fera si
je suis un électeur de gauche et que
j'aime pas macron ce type je trouve
qu'il me va pas personnellement je dis
je voterai pas pour lui et puis vous
vous retrouvez entre marine macron
pouvez vous dire je continue à penser ce
que je pensais ya quinze jours je pars à
la campagne je vais à la pêche mais vous
pouvez aussi vous dire quand même
comme dit le proverbe républicains ont
poli et auront choisi au second tour on
élimine et du coup on va éliminer marine
et ce genre de ce genre de choses on ne
peut pas les mesurer finement avant
parce qu'il faut être dans la situation
il faut le passage à l'acte comme
diraient les psychanalystes bon pour eux
pour choisir vraiment aller on va
terminer en donnant la parole à d'autres
candidats on n'a pas encore entendu dans
ce débat dans ce sens public et oui la
règle de l'égalité absolue des gens de
parole nicolas dupont aignan nathalie
arthaud et jean lassalle
électoralisme conduit à la résignation
et à la passivité lorsqu'on est
conscient que la force des travailleurs
ne se trouve pas dans les yeux il faut
faire un vote militant un vote pour
montrer son camp sa politique ses
perspectives aux autres travailleurs
elle ne cherche pas forcément être
extrême droitisée elle ne cherche pas à
être extrêmement gauchisé elle ne
cherche pas être extrêmement crown ise
elle cherche tout simplement à
se réunir et à se rassembler comme elle
a su le faire
lorsque la foudre avait frappé
il suffit que 2 3 millions de français
avaient voté en plus
et alors s'il y en a 10 millions en plus
toutes les cartes sont rebattues moi je
peux accéder au second tour e mc roupe
sortir le pen peut sortir le hybrid ou
nicolas dupont aignan qui s'était rallié
à marine le pen y à il ya cinq ans on
peut imaginer que l'art chartier qu'elle
le laisse au bord de la route cette fois
ci mais si on parle de ralliement tiens
si on termine là dessus on est au
lendemain du premier tour les sondages
n'ont pas été infirmé par par le vote
donc on a un duel emmanuel macron marine
le pen
comment ça peut se passer ça comment
vous imaginez les ralliements autour de
la candidate du rassemblement national
c'est-à-dire zemmour elle est déjà bien
parti de ce côté là puisque
environ 80% si j'ai bien lu serait
partant pour effectivement reporter leur
voix les sympathisants d'un accès moore
si on arrive ne pas l inverse ce n'est
pas tout à fait vrai c'est quand même un
peu plus forts de ce côté là donc elle a
déjà un sacré un sacré un point de ce
côté là une partie peut-être
effectivement des mélenchonistes
pourquoi pas parce qu'elle a quand même
un discours profondément social et sur
certains points c'est vrai qu'on
pourrait presque confondre ce n'était la
xénophobie quand même patente de la dix
candidates ont coûté c'est vrai que
c'est assez confondant donc elle a est
là
je parle elle en veut pas c'est vrai
elle ne fera pas elle ne fera pas
d'appel de ralliement de négociations
elle est dans une situation inédite pour
elle où elle peut directement s'adresse
aux lecteurs puisque 20 des réserves on
le disait tout à l'heure donc elle n'est
pas dans une stratégie du tout de
meeting commun ni de ralliements de
personnalités ben voila merci beaucoup
d'avoir répondu à toutes ses questions
bon et on va maintenir quand même un peu
de d'incertitude possible roland cayrol
oui il convient de dire en fin de
campagne que tout est toujours possible
bon mais
il arrive quand même que les choses
préjuge pas square pendant encore cinq
jours six jours pour pour en débattre
comment on pourrait se demander en
attendant ce que disent par exemple mes
trois amis ici on pourrait se demander
si puisque macro est hélas plus de 25%
pendant plus d'un an s'il est toujours
en tête du premier tour on va se dire
qu'il ya un mystère un type qui conduit
si mal sa campagne il n'avait pas qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à formuler un projet
qu'il suscite pas l'enthousiasmé qu'est
ce qui se passe quand même pu me vaincre
nous l'expliquent on essaiera de faire
dans la semaine et deux semaines qui
suivent le premier tour merci à tous
rappel le titre de ce
livre que vous avez publié aux éditions
de l'aube avec la fondation jean jaurès
l'opinion des émotions